hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today we're going to be
talking about my first impressions of
Vinland saga now I should say that
usually for a first impressions video I
would be looking at a handful of
episodes or even just one if it was a
particularly new series however I come
to you today have been completely
destroyed all 13 available episodes of
villain saga so that should tell you
that I'm going to have a pretty
favorable opinion right off the bat but
the thing is I just couldn't stop every
time an episode ended I was left with an
uncontrollable desire for more and now
I'm in a state of craving because I've
joined the ranks of weekly watches I
don't think that's too terrible though
because one of the things I love most
about this series so far is that every
episode for you know the 24 minutes or
so you get you know maybe my like 21
minutes after you take the opening in
the ending away whatever the case they
feel absolutely packed so as much as I
immediately want more after they finish
I always feel like they do provide a
solid condensed experience with a lot to
take in in terms of story character
moments and general atmosphere and you
know it just on that last point it's
quite amazing how Finland saga manages
to bring its environment to life every
landscape shot and capsule eats its own
brand of beauty whether it's the
pristine snow of Iceland the muted tones
of autumn England or even in some of the
most hellish conditions imaginable the
environment is still stunning and
incredibly immersive it's such a breath
of fresh air after coming from a string
of series that don't really place much
emphasis or detail in regards to making
the world a character of its own like
Demon Slayer for example I praise the
hell out of that but I would never call
the environment character of its own it
was more of a stage for characters to
act upon which is fine but in Vinland
saga the wall becomes an actor itself
and I love that because it means that
even in the slower less action II
moments there is still plenty going on
to captivate me but that really is just
the beginning of what hooked me on this
series because the actual characters are
so incredibly strong not physically
although mostly physically actually but
just all-round well written performed
and animated and there is no more
prominent example in my mind than a
Scott and I'm just so confused about how
to feel in regards to his existence in
general on the one hand I find him to be
probably the most intriguing character
in the entire series every time he's on
screen I do find myself paying that
little bit of extra attention because he
has a certain charm about him that I
find quite difficult to describe
honestly like I know that he is a
horrible person who has committed
numerous
disgusting acts right in front of my
face for the most part but at the same
time I can't help but root for him in
almost any given situation the one
exception to this being when he fought
up against Thor's but everything after
that I've always found myself in a
position where I want to see this man
progressed I want to know what he's
thinking and view his plans come to
fruition because he's a great thinker
and that leads me to believe that the
story is far more interesting with him
than without him and that makes
situations like his Jules against orphan
very conflicting for me because I do
also want to see Thor fin keep getting
closer and closer and eventually take
revenge if possible but I also want ask
a lot to continue being a prominent
presence of inland saga so for those
scenes especially the latest you'll they
do carry some nice tension as a result
plus he's just so damn mysterious I love
that I can never predict what he's going
to do because as soon as I feel like I'm
comfortable with the character he just
goes in you know his slice of someone's
head off out of nowhere and that reminds
me right he's a dick but it also makes
me go Leyna he's a dick but he must have
some sort of plan if he did that and as
a result I think it would be very
difficult to ask for a better antihero
style presence to follow but as for the
character who I suppose acts as the
protagonist we have Thor Finn and I'm
similarly invested in him not quite to
the same degree though big or small I am
completely on board with his quest for
revenge I think it has made him a bit
OneNote so far he's very much the polar
opposite of a Scot because I feel like I
always know what Thorin is thinking and
feeling which i think is an intentional
juxtaposition that results in making
Thoth in less mysterious however it does
make him very easy to empathize with and
use as a vehicle for the audience's
journey
so even when Thor Fionn is doing
horrific things it's still very easy to
be on board with him as well as quite
painful when we do see him suffer which
is you know pretty much his entire
existence in villain saga however I do
remember one particular moment at the
end of the episode where he fought
thorkil where he was just completely
broken and trudging along the road but
this wash of misery all over his face it
was such a well-done moment and it's one
of those scenes that makes me double
down on my support for this kid and I'm
really interested to see if his journey
concludes with the revenge he lost after
so much well whether he will adopt his
father's words that nobody is his enemy
and finally start living a life for
himself speaking of his father
Thor's was quite the character even if
you discount the opening which made his
future death pretty clear he was death
flagged quite heavily because you soon
enough realized that nobody this good
can survive in a world like this I did
really liked the idea that one day on
the battlefield he just
feeling empty and decided you know what
no more of this because surely everyone
reaches that point with everything if
not for the fact that you're realizing
how much pain and suffering you're
causing in regards to fighting then
perhaps for the idea that you've done it
so much that it just becomes boring I
mean obviously thor's isn't the type of
person to be in that second category but
I did still enjoy that aspect of the
retired warrior there's very little
about the characters in Vinland saga
that I don't enjoy in general ER every
character who has had any sort of focus
seems to be very well-written and for
the most part two very morally ambiguous
you know with the exception of Thor's
but even then he was a warrior and
committed many many atrocities but for
example like Thor Finn's sister she's
quite likable for the most part quirky
witty etc you know she might also be a
horrible person because she constantly
wants to engage in the slave trade and
was actually crying over the loss of the
sheep it cost to put a human being
properly to rest and then there are
characters like Ragnar who I do not like
in the slightest I think he has an ugly
design I've never been able to identify
with a single word he said and he's
boringly simple as well as somewhat
stupid however he does somehow command a
strong presence within the series with
those traits regardless he feels like a
very solid character and I appreciate
that as well as Vinland sagas commitment
to involving primary characters with you
know less than aesthetically pleasing
designs I think that it adds quite
nicely to the immersion because there
would be nothing worse than a gritty
historical drama being performed
exclusively like beautiful and sleek
looking characters which to be fair
there are still quite a lot of actually
just on that another thing I like about
Thor Fionn is that despite being the
wind I typical boy he did not evolve
into a classic anime handsome
protagonist he's actually for all
intents and purposes quite regular
looking you know not necessarily ugly
but in no way is stand out anything and
there are probably some people out there
who will disagree a great length about
that which is fine but I quite like the
villain Sokka has embraced a more
realistic view of the world and its
residents in fact in general the series
has quite an intriguing brutal charm
about it but at the same time it feels
quite nicely balanced with action drama
and even the odd bit of comedy like the
brutality isn't overwhelming to the
point but it becomes an exercise in
depression to simply watch an episode
however there is just enough of it to
remind us of the stakes of the world
without going overboard into any sort of
realm of misery porn which I find is
often a danger in this kind of series
and something else that deserves mention
is the music of course it is a character
in the series as much as the landscapes
and is a key factor in shaping the
experience of the viewer I also really
love the opening in the ending the first
opening and ending that is we've
recently gotten a new set and I don't
hate them it's just going to take some
time to let them sink in because I've
started to associate that first opening
especially with this world so having
something new come in will always take
some adjusting one thing I do wish is
that the first opening for all of its
glorious sound did not contain blatant
spoilers for the first half of the
series and yeah I get that this is a
common anime thing and in Japan spoilers
are actually used to gather an audience
rather than push them away which I've
always found to be an interesting
phenomena but I don't know I just wish
that I didn't know what Thorin was going
to become before he embarked on that
journey I wish I didn't know that he was
going to join us colada thanks to seeing
them both on the same ship in the
opening and so many many many more
things a lot of which was actually
scenes from future episodes being
plunked in and I get that the Thor fin
stuff would have been really difficult
if not completely impossible to keep out
of the opening because his adolescent
form makes up the bulk of the series or
at least that's what I'm assuming but at
the same time there were a good what
five episodes before he actually grew to
the point that the opening showed him in
that's quite a bit of time to keep
plodding along with near exact knowledge
of what's to come and hey it's not a big
issue because Finland soccer is just so
damn good but I just prefer to go into
things a bit more blind than that and
the standard response I'm going to get
this is well just don't watch the
openings lull which is great but that
doesn't do me a whole lot of good after
I've already seen it the first time and
made all of those connections whatever
the case it does not matter because the
journey is worth taking even if the
destination is known beforehand look
Finland saga is an undeniable shard of
glory in this anime season if it keeps
going the way it has and I have no
reason to believe that it won't and I
think it's a solid contender for the
best series of 2019 and for good reason
it's fantastically animated well paced
wonderfully performed and a never
intriguingly written piece of media I
find it so difficult to point out flaws
with this series but the best I can
offer is the slight annoyance at
spoilers in the opening and that should
tell you what a nifty series this is
because I am very capable of criticizing
the hell out of anything but it's also
refreshing because Finland saga doesn't
take place in Japan or any place based
on Japan in fact there are some points
in the series where I actually forget
that they're speaking Japanese that's
how immersed I became in this and just
quickly that's another thing actually I
really like how they treat language in
the show I mean everyone is obviously
speaking Japanese for the sake of the
audience but there is constant reference
to not understanding what someone else
is saying
because they're speaking Norse English
or Welsh whatever and it adds a nice
layer of realistic complexity to the
situation at hand rather than everyone
being able to magically understand each
other and it does so without having
actors actually trying to speak those
languages although to be perfectly
honest I would love to see the Japanese
attempt to speak Welsh because it's kind
of like the anti-japanese actually
because their words have so few vowels
and Japanese is all about vowel sounds
but finally the thing that sold me most
initially on Finland saga is that it
began in Iceland so it activated all
kinds of nostalgia for me because
Iceland is one of the most beautiful
countries I've ever been to expensive as
hell but it's like stepping into another
world entirely and I think that the
anime really captured that magical
aspect of Iceland quite nicely by the
way if you're of a keen for a magical
story about Iceland and look up that one
time that one of their construction
companies was forced to unearth an elf
rock because elves started causing a
series of mishaps with their machinery
and no I am NOT jerking elves are a very
established presence in Iceland but to
bring this back around
I love Finland saga great series so far
and I look forward to tuning in for the
next 11 or so weeks to see it continue
but that pretty much does it for my
first impressions of Finland sorry if
you enjoyed this video and the content
this channel produced in general and
please do consider donating to the new
worldview patreon because the support of
all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my desk or server where a wide array of
shenanigan takes place on a daily basis
and finally please do comment with your
thoughts on Vinland saga this has been
the new world review and i'll see you
next time